[Musique]
amy peut venir de partout ils peuvent
être proches peut être joué à cause
d'une internet des souris cette bande
qui avait déverse explosive le temps
nous attaquer comme si l'attaqué est
trop
les explosions des déflagrations des
engins explosifs je compte même plus les
fautes style
[Musique]
c'est l'histoire d'un homme ébranlé
transformer le sergent david de rue a
participé à trois missions en
afghanistan avec le royal 22e régiment
entre 2007 et 2011 avant de revenir dans
sa gaspésie natale chaque fois il a
côtoyé la mort souvent celles de civils
afghans on était là pour protéger la
population civile kocakurt surtout les
femmes et des enfants qui étaient
lisibles 15 mai numéro un ce raid en
attaque là on était prête à donner
jusqu'à notre dernier sauf pour protéger
ces gens là les protégés je t'amène des
talibans qui leur faisait subir ces
atrocités le
quelques semaines avait un accident
fatal qu'ils emportaient au cours de ces
trois missions en poste avancé le
sergent le rue a aussi perdu plusieurs
de ses camarades d expérience pénible
dont il a encore du mal à parler
aujourd'hui il y avait oui c'est
malheureux mais c'est humain un goût de
vengeance sur les talibans l'important
c'est pas morts pour rien mario est pas
pour rien sunshine sais c'est que le
chef du shin bet el hadj ameth remercie
se sont pas morts pour rien on va leur
faire regretter
david l'heureux a rapporté dans ses
bagages des images intense des
souffrances refoulé physique et
psychologique et une immense détresse
le ps est de revenir à la vie normale
parce que tu as toujours un peu en
arrière goût l'impression qui est à
peaufiner en mission il ya quelque chose
qui marche qu'au de l'hyper vigilance
est encore le ton niveau de stress et
d'anxiété est anormalement élevé pour
une situation normale que ça ne devrait
pas avoir lieu avec les dommages au
système nerveux et se font
tranquillement produits
pas mal de l'air c'est vraiment pas un
jouet pour moi c'est une activité zen
pendant ce temps le suspense a rien
d'autre cette permis de décrocher
le sergent à la retraite a été surpris
lui aussi de la rapidité avec laquelle
les talibans ont repris le contrôle du
pays au cours des dernières semaines des
souvenirs intenses refont surface voilà
près traîne je fauché un maudit du
résultat c'est venu me chercher
ça vient encore me chercher parce
qu'encore une fois ci les civils qui en
paye là pis encore une fois si les
femmes paysans afin qu'apple a pris en
afghanistan
en 2014 le sergent a pris sa retraite il
a tenté un changement de carrière puis a
réalisé que c'était impossible je vais
l'essayer fait sur et souffrait de
troubles de stress post traumatique qui
n'avait pas encore été diagnostiqués
dans ses pires moments c'est sur la vie
était vraiment dans sa bulle à lui image
que j'utilise qui avait d'avir dans un
bloc de glace dans un immense bloc de
béton lui y est tellement serré le thé
en afghanistan encore moi je fais du par
les puits
safran des paul et moi j'étais riche
insultes je suis revenu
je trouve que c'est un petit prix à
payer pour tout le bien qu'on a fait sur
l'intérêt pour les poètes et le pouvoir
rien mais là maintenant justement grâce
aux thérapies aux ressources qui a été
chercher puis je le dis ça l'a
énormément aidé l'homme et nay émergent
puis est capable de voir qu'une vie
après tout seul est capable de se rendre
compte que d'autres choses à travers mes
enfants selon les spécialistes il peut
s'écouler de nombreuses années avant que
les symptômes de ce manifeste chez des
soldats david l'heureux lui a commencé
ses traitements tout récemment soit dix
ans après son retour au pays les images
des événements récents survenus en
afghanistan pourrait bien réveiller le
bal qui ronge de nombreux autres soldats
qui ont vécu cette guerre de près
aujourd'hui je peux je peux simplement
dit que j malgré le résultat malgré ce
qui se fait à quoi je dois vivre avec
autant physiquement que
psychologiquement
j'en sors plus fort qui gagne
parce que j'y inclus de tous ceux
pour ce que je souhaitais ministre et
frère d'armes aller chercher ces
ressources le
pour que ces jarres le plus les aider